[موسيقى]
شيماء
كلاسيكو مدريد
فرصه في الاتحاد الاوروبيه
بشكل اساسيه يقول باننا ندعم منظمه سياسيه
لا تصب في مصلحه اوروبا باكملها نحن
نستطيع العمل مع الدول الاوروبيه وهذا ما
نفعله غالبا ولا يوجد سبب يمنعنا من
الوحده مع اوروبا لا شيء في بركزه همم يقف
بالضروره ضد التعاون الدوري كما شاهدنا
على سبيل المثال معناتهم اهون عليك وضعته
اوكرانيا مع روسيا والعديد من الدول
الاوروبيه اجتمعت
لمقاومه ما يجري بغض النظر عن العضويه في
الاتحاد
الكبيره مثل الان لم تكن جزءا من هذه
الجهود فلا اعتقد ان الاتحاد الاوروبي
يمثل اوروبا ولا اعتقد انه يمثل التعاون
اظنه اوروبا واعتقدوا بينزل تمنعنا من عمل
في اوروبا
[موسيقى]
ترحيب السؤال هو هنالك العديد من حالات
انعدام الاستقرار والازمات اقتصاديه ازمه
الحكومه داخل المحافظين الذين
هو بالشكل الذي يدور بالمنطقه على الشعب
البريطاني لدينا ازمه الاسكان
الذين ازمات في كل ركن وكليب اعتقدنا
البلاد باكملها
كيف اعبر عن الامر ان تعيش في ضرف هي
بحاجه الى قائد الشجاع يتخذ قرارات ليست
شعبيه ولكنه يتمكن من اعاده الاستقرار
وهذا يعني وجود فتره من انعدام الاستقراري
في نفس الوقت
[موسيقى]